on this episode we got shut down
[Music]
[Music]
ask Gary B alright I'll go in the selfie
mode until she gets here what up animal
what up Tucker good to see Tom looks
like oh there's India let's see let's
track India let's track India's walk to
doing the show there she is in the mix
in New York City there she is
here she comes
there she is
hi India you're on Facebook live hey how
you doing you ready to go this is
Rockefeller Center right this is
actually really cool cool ready
yes you want to do anything kind of like
cool or no wow my shoes very white 169
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is sub 169 on the ask gary vee
show this really works out nicely we are
at Rockefeller Center it's pretty the
rock did you show the skating ring it's
really nice it's really nice and feels
very festive this time of year good to
be here a beautiful Friday morning in
New York I don't know I can't the big
global warming because I'm just not
educated and any shape or form on the
issue but man it's nice to be nice and
warm in December and not wear a coat and
I'm excited huge jets-giants game
actually decided in the shower this
morning that I don't want to predict it
I really don't I just don't have that
feel anymore I'm sorry I know so many
people want the prediction I will make
one prediction Odell Beckham may
literally break all-time NFL records no
Revis no Marcus Williams we're on our
third corner it's gonna get ugly out
there I see the Giants putting up a lot
of passing yards I'm very concerned in
the very concerned get in here what are
you scared if you're wearing it do you
feel like the cops could arrest you or
how do you rock shot got it all right
it's good to see you India alright let's
do this Kalina asks any advice for
people working 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 a.m.
doing what they love but aren't sure how
to monetize it such as a blog Helena
yeah you know Helen I think um you know
I think it's dangerous not to have a
concept of how you're gonna monetize if
you want money as a KPI meaning I need
everybody understand there's a
difference between strategy and patience
you need to be patient to execute your
strategy but you need a strategy like
you know and and by the way strategy's
very easy if you're building a personal
brand or if you're talking about coffee
or things of that nature whatever you're
doing there's a lot of ways to sell you
sell as being a personality you show up
in events to get paid for that you you
make a book and you sell that you know
you create a product like a coffee maker
and you sell that there's not a lot of
different ways to monetize and make
money you make it through advertising
you make it through appearance fees you
make it through selling stuff you know
it's quite basic so I've seen you time
on your strategy that's how you're gonna
monetize you're either gonna
siphon the leverage into a product a
service for your time that's it that's
your strategy I've told you you now know
how you're gonna do it now what you
really need to worry about is does
anybody give a crap about what you're
doing between 7 & 2 you know you can't
just talk about loving knitting or
loving sneakers but nobody thinks you're
good at it you know there's a little bit
of a meritocracy in this the market has
to care and if the market doesn't care
you lose Daniel ass I'm starting a
fatherhood blog how would you market it
I would go to Instagram and use every
and search every hashtag that you can
think of around fatherhood starting with
fatherhood as much less tumblr let's put
you to work can you quickly check how
many people have used the fatherhood
hashtag on Instagram I would go to
Twitter search and I go to Instagram
search and I would search the fatherhood
hashtag I would then look at the content
and I would engage with it I would do
that under the name of your blog not as
Rick four hundred and sixty four
thousand four hundred sixty four
thousand so there's 464176 you suck like
you kid
you know like be real jab don't be like
come to my blog it's really good you
want to learn more about fatherhood come
to might now that's spam engage in the
community work 15 hours a day grind
grind grind grind grind that is the
easiest and hardest way to do it the
other thing you could do is go and map
the 25 to 50 important fatherhood
blogs and platforms and ask to guest
blog and then you're siphoning that
audience now you have to write a good
blog cuz nobody will come over if you
stink and that would be another thing
I'd also scrap up a couple bucks I would
spend twenty to fifty dollars a week
instead of buying a shake or taking an
uber or going to see Star
you know take that 20 and 50 bucks and
buy Facebook ads against dads that show
interest about being a dad there's a
million things you can do India I'm a
little angry I'm excited that was fun
that was very that was very like I've
been talking about crushing since 2009
let's get our [ __ ] together people
that's what that was Eric Eric wants to
know what makes a company more
investable millions of active users
consuming free content or millions in
actual profit millions of actual profit
I haven't done an answer where I didn't
expand on it in a long time I picked
this moment to do that Carter Carter
asked how do you prepare for a big
meeting or anything where you're
required to have a strong performance
Carter I prepare for a big meeting by
living my life meaning
I am always prepared for a big meeting
thus I never prepare for a big meeting
meaning when you're when you are great
at something or very good at something
you don't need any prep time because
you're always prepping right and so
that's the punchline of me in a
professional meeting standpoint like the
years of experience the bravado the
results the cadence the the natural
skills the the two things that matter
practice and natural talent have been
there so I don't prepare for a big
meeting it's not like I get pumped up I
don't put it like Lil Wayne and be like
all right we're gonna go get it like
there's none of that there's no like
looking in the mirror be like okay we're
gonna win this [ __ ] there's none of
that [ __ ] I put in the work every
day 365 to be ready for that and I think
any money that's very good at something
is always doing that you know you don't
just wake up and decide you're gonna be
good at something
you're always preparing you know it's
like it's like if you're if you're if
you're preparing in a tactic way you're
unprepared
yeah that was you like that right there
was some deep bass [ __ ] right yeah I
mean like like like how am I gonna
prepare to cook a great meal for these
homies right now the answer is I'm not
there's no reading a blog post or
watching a YouTube video or calling a
chef friend like I'm gonna [ __ ] it up I
haven't done anything for 40 years that
preps me to cook a good meal to you
that was some high level [ __ ] oh I have
so much more energy when there's other
human beings around like literally I'm
like feel I'm like they feel it like
this dude right here this big man is
giving me energy Samantha I gotta listen
right I have headphones then I got it
phones BAM
right in your face India I'm very
competitive right now here plug this
said
publicly
this is private thing open
okay no worries we'll just send it all
right guys you heard the man
we have to listen you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
yeah
thank you so much for never keep down
what you do man thank you
do that
was like oh I had a meeting
you don't want to bother sometimes like
you know
yeah I can't I get when I see Jeff
players I get so hot that I've never
bother
yes be right
[Music]